I was pretty lost looking for a new anime
this season mainly because of how surprising
Spring 2021 was towards the last few weeks from
the astronomical endings of both Odd Taxi and
Link Click and so it almost felt a bit unfair to
Summer 2021 to stand in the shadows of such huge
anime to walk in those footsteps, and I had a tough
time scrubbing for something new to interest me
And then I tried out a show I'd heard whispers
about little tidbits and mentions of here and
there and I gave it a shot,
that show being ofcourse,
Sonny Boy
Sahnny Boy?
Sony Boy?
Now I want to preface by making it clear that I don't think
Sonny Boy is the only good show this season if that
was what was implied by the title, it's much more
simple than that, it's really just the only one
I'm currently watching–or the only original one
actually because I am watching Kobayashi-san 2 butuh
so yeah I guess there's a lot of discrepancies with
that title...
But anyway I felt like there might be
a lot of this season too who are confused on what
to watch or have yet to see any standouts yet,
and I wanted to make this video to convince you
to watch Sonny Boy, or at least to give it a try
because I think it has a lot of potential and it
has already piqued my interest only two episodes
in, which is pretty difficult to do, so yeah
let's check it out
I think the reason thatSonny Boy already started receiving hype andanticipation before the show even aired,
why I heard about it in the first place was because
it's actually being directed by Shingo Natsume,
who you might recognize as the director of One
Punch Man season one, which you know probably needs
no introduction on that one
*OPS1 OP aggressively playing*
And mind you I want to
make it clear that it's One Punch Man season ONE
NOT season two, which was given to JCSTAFF
instead of Madhouse–who directed season one–and
so Sonny Boy is kind of like compensation it seems
for everyone who felt disappointed in One Punch
Man season 2 and wanted to go back to the roots of
the anime with Shingo Natsume and Madhouse studios
who directed the original show that blew up and
impressed just about everyone across the world
plus this series is based on no source material at
all, meaning that it is written and is essentially
all up to the creative directive of Shingo Natsume,
even more reason to believe that this is kind of
like his comeback after that, after such a big
impact on the anime community Sonny Boy is his
new project, and he's also assisted by a great
staff: original character designs from Hisashi
Ogushi who worked on Perfect Blue
which is another pretty famous movie
so to make a long story short the cast working
on this show has a pretty strong reputation that
had people already wanting to see what was in
store from the start before the show even aired
but that is probably the line I draw the only part
of Sonny Boy that I can compare to One Punch man
season one and honestly I don't think you could
even find any similarities plot wise because
Sonny Boy is very...
Strange
I'd say
The premiseof Sonny Boy is very simple, very short todescribe;
One day a school drifts into an alternate
dimension of nothingness and the only people who
are left are 36 boys and girls in the school, but
some of them also begin to develop superpowers
And,
and that's about it
There's basically no
backstory on anyone to start off with nothing to
build up to this moment you are immediately thrown
into Sonny Boy
Now, normally I get kind of turnedaway from series that solely involved teenagersamidst some mystery or dangerous power,
it's a genre that is often done really poorly,
Mayoiga,
Danganronpa,
don't even get me started on King'sGame
All of these kinds of supernatural stories
with dark twists involving just a cast of students,
don't have a great track record for whatever
reason and, one of the reasons from the start that
I think (Sonny Boy) stood out was because of the characters
or at least the main cast in the first episode or
two, they feel very unique, there's this really
interesting dynamic between the student council
and the normal students. The student council is
basically led by this guy named Hoshi who is
this very conniving looking guy who almost seems
evil at surface level but is contrasted by how he
acts as he's one of the three heads of the school
basically, one of the few characters who is trying
to make sure that things don't get out of hand
which, we know they will of course it's a group
of teenagers with superpowers. It almost reminds
me of lord of the flies if you're similar with
that series it was one of those for some reason
every school forced you to watch in elementary
school but basically it follows a bunch of
kids who are stranded on an abandoned island
and very quickly they resort to savagery and
almost primal life that goes really badly it's
one of the forbearers of the genre of kids with no
adult supervision start going crazy to sum it up
Which would have probably happened in sunnyboy
actually if it weren't for the student council
who take the rules very seriously in this show
they are the commanding power there is a level
of superiority about them and it's because the
show has superpowers because the student council
have the ability to enforce their rule and make
sure that people don't step out of line it's
not an equal playing grounds like the stories like
this mostly are this dynamic is the most important
part of episode 1 by far, it really sets a certain
tone for the show to come, that even though it's a
bunch of kids - not only will it get out of hand
at times, but conflict will arise certainly that
needs to be solved among themselves and they need
to have order.
It's pretty mature ideas, despitethe young cast
And another aspect that I think
is really important to Sonny Boy growing success
is the mystery, because once again bringing
up Spring 2021 and two of the most successful
original shows of the season–Odd Taxi and
Link Click–they're both mysteries
2021 isvery much elevating this genre to new levels or
at least putting it back in the spotlight, which I
personally love, it's amazing to be enthralled in a
really good mystery it's one of my favorite genres
and of course Sonny Boy is guaranteed to be a
mystery because the biggest issue of the show
is finding out why the hell all of these students
are trapped in some strange dimension and why they
suddenly have powers is this part of earth is
there a way to escape how do they even get here
Is this part of earth?
Is there a way to escape?
How did they even get here?
I think Sonny Boy has an endless amount of
possible ways it can go which is kind of
scary actually, because the series could end up
being way different from how we initially expect
it could be like aliens making the dimension
or some experiment gone wrong or just some
weird supernatural world they live in that we
didn't even expect, like it could be anything
at this rate, but regardless I think the idea of
giving these students powers on top of everything
does add depth to the show and they're all very
different too it's it's not like my hero where all
of them are used for one specific purpose for
fighting villains, one of them has like Animal
Crossing items that he can make from nothing
and give to other people, and one can fly, and
one can dish out punishments how he sees fit to
people and force them to do his bidding almost
it's it's really dynamic it keeps you on your toes,
but all this praise isn't to say that the show is
perfect or anything like that because I think it'sfar from perfect especially with only two or threeepisodes now down
For one as I mentioned earlier,
I can definitely see the story really spiraling
in later episodes once we find the reason that the
kids are trapped in some alternate dimension like
a Gurren Lagann type story where they suddenly end
up fighting God in space, or Attack on Titan where
we suddenly realize that there's an entire world
outside of these walls, which can definitely be
done right because both of the shows that I just
mentioned did this concept perfectly but because
there isn't an original manga that Sonny Boy is
based off of, it's just a completely original
story it can definitely get out of hand and no one
is there to control it except for Shingo Natsume
and even if he has a great reputation, people make
mistakes, I also think the main character Nagara is
kind of lackluster, he doesn't have really anything
of note to his character except that he's kind of
quiet and mysterious and apathetic towards
things, which I do think will end up being
important later on but, right now he's just kind
of mindlessly there in the story for me without
doing much for his own it's kind of carried by
the other more dynamic and interesting characters
So I'm looking forward to see how he grows and if
he doesn't then that'll be pretty disappointing
So yeah today was a pretty short video in all
honesty, it's it's hard to say a lot about this
show because there's so few episodes out and
do normally like to take a more analytical route
but I felt like it was important to bring light
to Sonny Boy before it potentially gets big which
I can definitely see happening
What are your guys' thoughts on it? Have you seen it?
Are you interested by what I said? If not at all,
what are other shows that you're watching thisseason?
I'd love to hear some
As always this hasbeen the Anime Culture Corner, I hope you enjoyedthe video
don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and character analyses